có khu khí trang nghiệm và sức đầu, và lại biểu các cao đảng nhắn nước
về nằm ra động chỉ trận cầm tố, quyvian bộ chính trị
thương trực bán bị thương giận đầu, và lại biểu các cao chính phủ
ra động chỉ lên mình hơn, quyvian bộ chính trị thủ tưởng chỉ khu giận đầu,
và lại biểu các cao khu hội ra động chỉ đô văn chiến,
quyvian bộ chính trị, có trụ tịch thương trực có vội giận đầu,
đã vào biểun và đặt vòng hát tưởng niệm đồng chỉ
chủ tịch của hội lao sai sống phôn phôn vih hạnh.
Các hồng qua của các bạn đều mang động chỉ ước vô cùng thương tiết
đồng chỉ xây sống phôn phôn phôn phôn phôn phôn phôn
xuất lộng gì vào xuất an, các đồng chỉ lãng đảo
khức cao đại viện xuất đảng nhắn nước khu hội và chính phủ.
Mày tỏ nềm tích thương vô hạnh trước sự ra đi của đồng chỉ
chủ tịch có vội lao xây sống phôn phôn phôn vih hạnh.
Các nhắn đảo Việt Nam nhắn mạnh, đồng chỉ xây sống phôn phôn vih hạnh
là buồn nhà lãnh đảo xuất sắc, tận tuy của đảng nhắn nước
khu hội và nhắn gần lao.
Với bạn gắn bỏ thủ chúng phổ đảng nhắn nước khu hội chính phủ và nhắn rất Việt Nam.
Đồng chỉ xây sống phôn phôn phôn vih hạnh luôn dành tình cảm xong nạn
và có nhiều đón có tích cử trong việc cùng phố phát triển mối quan hệ hiệu bị bị đại
và các đặc biệt, các phản viện gắn kết chính lực Việt Nam lao.
Sự ra đi của đồng chỉ, câu chỉ là mất mắt to lớn đồn với đảng
nhắn nước, nhắn dân lao ảnh em, phát rác chuyện đồng chỉ
tổn thời lao sự tổn thống lớn lao khổ đảng nhắn nước và nhắn dân Việt Nam.
Đảng nhắn nước và nhắn dân Việt Nam
luôn đi nhớ và chân sọng những cấu viến
đóng có to lớn của đồng chỉ trong việc của đặc,
cùng cụ và phát triển mối quan hệ hiệu bị bị đại
và thêm đặc biệt, các thác phản viện gắn kết chính lực Việt Nam lao.
Thủ tướng chính phủ lên mình hơn,
hương trợ bán bí thư trình cảm tủ,
có chủ tịch tụng sự phố khổ đồng văn chiến bày tỏ nềm tiếp thương,
chân thành chiếc buồn tới đại sử lào tại Việt Nam,
khám pháo ơn thà văn về việc đồng chỉ chủ tịch của hội xây sống khôn thôn
tí hạn thư trình,
quá đồng chỉ đại sử lời trường buồn sâu sách tới các đồng chỉ lãnh đạo
nạn nhắn nước,
phố hội chính phủ nhân dân lao và giác viến đồng chỉ xây sống
phôn thôn vih hạn.
Súp đồng trước sự quan tâm của đạn nhắn nước Việt Nam,
tại sự lao tại Việt Nam khám pháo ơn thà văn,
thay mặt đạn nhắn nước,
phố hội chính trường lao trên thành cảm ơn các đồng chỉ lãnh đạo đạn,
nhắn nước, phố hội chính phủ đã đến biến,
vì sổ tăng từng liệu đồng chỉ xây sống phôn phôn vih hạn.
Thế hiện xinh động tinh cảm gắn bó kéo sôn,
phủ chung, trong sáng và hiểu có giữa hai đảng,
hai nhắn nước và nhắn dân hai nước Việt Nam lao.
Cung ngày, đó này biểu một số bán bộ ngày và thề chung vương và điều cuân.
Đã đến biến, vì sổ tăng từng liệu đồng chỉ xây sống phôn phôn vih hạn
tại đại sử quán Việt Nam lao tại Việt Nam,
và các tổn lãnh sự quán lao tại thành phố hội chính miên và đạn nắng.